thanks to its beginnings is a
best-selling book World War Z seems
destined for box office glory someday
but that road to the big screen wasn't
always an easy one we're taking a look
back at the ending of World War Z and
how it got from prized source material
to hailed script to problem production
to box office head after the success of
his 2003 how-to manual the zombie
survival guide author Max Brooks decided
to take his love of The Walking Dead up
a notch his next book was a harrowing
oral history style novel said in the era
after the outbreak of a virus that
reanimates corpses and nearly wipes out
the human race in it a member of the UN
post-war commission travels to locations
around the world conducting interviews
to take the reader from the first
hotspots to the collapse of society to
the darkest moments when humanity finds
a way to fight back audiences responded
with great enthusiasm and World War Z
would top the New York Times bestseller
list eventually selling more than a
million copies with that level of
success it was only a matter of time
before Hollywood came calling and Brad
Pitt's company Plan B eventually landed
the rights Pitt brought on J michael
Straczynski a veteran genre writer
behind cult classics like Babylon 5 to
craft the first draft of the script
Straczynski version kept the interview
format of the book intact and his draft
was strong enough to attract director
Marc Forster to the project it was here
that the first signs of trouble in the
making of the film began to emerge fresh
off is James Bond film Quantum of Solace
Foresters ideas for World War Z clashed
with stress in skis and the director
asked for rewrites state of play writer
Matthew Michael Carnahan was brought in
to develop a new more action heavy
script and major changes were made
instead of focusing on the aftermath of
the war with the zombies the new script
placed Pitt's character Jerry Lane in
the middle of the outbreak from the
beginning Carnahan's
script was solid enough that shooting
could begin but studio executives still
weren't sure about the film's ending in
Carnahan's version of the story pits
Jerry Lane would endure everything from
a crash landing in Russia to a time jump
to an invasion
the west coast of the United States all
without ever reuniting with his family
eventually it was decided that rewrites
and reshoots were needed to get the film
and ship lost writer damon lindelof and
later the martian writer Drew Goddard
were brought in to offer tweaks to
Carnahan script what they eventually
delivered was an all-out expensive
redesign of the film's third act which
Paramount agreed the fund the film's
budget ballooned to at least 190 million
dollars and by the end of the shoot
Forrester and Pitt were reportedly not
on speaking terms anymore so after all
this back and forth where did we wind up
instead of crash landing in Russia
Lane's zombie-infested fight out of
Israel heads for a World Health
Organization facility in Wales as it's
coming in for a landing however the
zombies threatened to overrun everything
Lane and either a really brilliant or
really dumb move detonates a grenade
that tears a hole in the fuselage and
depressurizes the cabin leading to all
the zombies being sucked out and the
plane coming in for an intense crash
landing after a blackout Lane impaled by
a rather large piece of shrapnel wakes
up in the wreckage and tries to make his
way to the w-h-o outpost that was his
initial destination overcome by his
injuries he loses consciousness and
later awakes under the care of a w-h-o
doctor played by a future doctor who
star Peter Capaldi after regaining his
senses he comes to a shocking conclusion
having seen the zombie horde passed by
the sick and elderly he believes that
the virus drives its host to seek out
only healthy and viable victims to
facilitate its spread if this be the key
to humanity's survival wouldn't you know
it a w-h-o facility is just the place
for lain to test his theory that by
infecting oneself with a deadly but
curable pathogen it's possible to create
a sort of camouflage that will cause
zombies to ignore a potential victim the
only problem is that the lab containing
the types of pathogens he needs is in
the zombie infested part of the building
in order to figure this all out and
possibly save humanity Lane and his
companions have to embark on a sort of
stealth mission sneaking their way onto
a particular vault without alerting the
dormant undead wandering the halls here
we see the results of Lindelof
Goddard's effort to scale the action
down to a more personal level rather
than an epic battle were treated to a
tense game of cat and mouse as Lane and
company tiptoe their way toward the
relevant vault while they're eventually
separated Lane does get where he needs
to go once he's there however he's
trapped by a zombie blocking the accent
which is the perfect impetus for him to
conduct the kind of experiment that only
works in the movies injecting himself
with an unknown pathogen he then opens
the door only to find himself ignored by
every Sambi he encounters on his walk
back to freedom just walk quite
constantly back climax having happened
we then moved into a conclusion that
dovetails somewhat back toward the
larger geopolitical scope of the book
with lanes theory proven correct we see
the distribution of an injectable
vaccine brewed from a strain of
meningitis to people around the world as
humankind begins to fight back we see
scenes of various battles including some
of the footage of the Moscow fight from
the original cut sending zombies are
burned evacuations are conducted and a
note of hope on a global scale is
sounded keeping fright troit true to the
reworks purpose however the main focus
remains personal as Lane and his family
are happily reunited in a safe haven in
Nova Scotia hits voiceover speaks of a
war just begun but for his character it
seems the journey has ended in the best
possible place back together with his
wife and daughters and out of harm's way
it took a while for World War Z to
finally make the leap from page to
screen and the film version endured more
than its share of battle to get there
after all that would audiences respond
to the film yes they would World War Z
exploded to a box-office take of two
hundred and two point four million
dollars domestically and five hundred
forty million dollars worldwide which
were pretty great numbers for a film was
such a troubled production history it
also earned the biggest opening weekend
of Pitts career devouring sixty six
point four million dollars in its first
three days despite its troubles World
War Z's success showed that audiences
were still hungry for more zombie
stories even in a world already
saturated by the likes of zombie land
and The Walking Dead meanwhile ever
one involved emerged unscathed hit is
still a huge star and went on to hit a
career-high with 2019 s once upon a time
in Hollywood Straczynski moved on to
write the cult hit TV series sense8
Forrester directed Christopher Robin for
Disney and Damon Lindelof eventually
created one of 29 teens best new series
Watchmen not bad for the crew behind a
movie that as it staggered to its ending
seemed like it would probably be dead on
arrival check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite movies are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]